in spite of all this he would still have
been received at Cumbre he was of course
hardly friend my parents would have
chosen for me they had in the end
decided that the tears which he had shed
on hearing of my grandmother's illness
were genuine enough but they knew either
instinctively or from their own
experience that our early impulsive
emotions have a little influence over
our later actions and the conduct of our
lives and then regard for moral
obligations little oil tea to our
friends patience in finishing our work
obedience to a regimen have a sure
foundation in habits solidly formed and
blindly followed then in these momentary
transports hardened and sterile they
would have preferred to block as
companions for myself boys who would
have given me no more than it is proper
for one boy to give to another who would
not unexpectedly send me a basket of
fruit because they happened that morning
to have thought of me with affection but
who being incapable of inclining in my
favour by any single impulse of their
imagination and Sensibility the exact
balance of the duties and claims of
friendship whereas incapable of loading
the scales to my detriment even our
faults will not easily divert from the
path of their duty toward us those
conventional natures of which my great
aunt was the model who estranged for
years from a nice to whom she never
spoke yeah made no change in the will
that she had left that nice in which she
had left that meets the whole of her
fortune because she was her next of kin
and it was the proper thing to do but I
was fond of block my parents wished me
to be happy and the insoluble problems
that I set myself on such texts as the
absolutely meaningless beauty of life he
did aminos it pacifying tired me more
and made me more unwell
would have further talks with him
although my mother judged them
pernicious and he would still have been
received at Cumbre but for one thing
that same night after dinner having
informed me a piece of news that had a
great influence on my later life making
it happier at one time and then unhappy
that no woman ever thought of anything
but love and that there was not one of
them whose resistance a man could not
overcome he had gone on to assure me
that he had heard it said on
unimpeachable authority that my
great-aunt herself had led a stormy life
in her youth and had been notoriously
tapped I could not refrain from passing
on so important piece of information to
my parents the next time when called he
was not admitted and afterward when I
met him on the street he greeted me with
extreme coldness but in the matter of
dark God he had spoken truly for the
first few days like a tomb that one will
become mad about but which one does not
have first discerned the things I was to
love so passionately in his style were
not yet clear to me I could not lay down
the novel of his that I was reading but
I thought that I was interested in the
subject alone as in the first dawn of
love when we go every day to meet a
woman at some party or entertainment pie
the delights of which we believe
ourselves attractive then I observed the
rare almost archaic expressions that he
liked to employ at certain points where
a hidden flow of harmony an internal
prelude would elevate his style and it
was at such points as these too that he
would begin to speak of the vain dream
of life of the inexhaustible torrid
affair forms of the
Stara splendid torture of understanding
and loving of the moving effigies that
are noble for all time the charming and
venerable facades of our cathedrals that
he would express a whole system of
philosophy new to me by the use of
marvelous imagery - the inspiration of
which one would have ascribed that song
of harps that arose then and to the
accompaniment of which that that imagery
gave something sublime one of these
passages of Bergamo the third or fourth
that I detached from the rest filled me
with a joy to which the joy I felt in
the first born no comparison a joy I
felt myself too experienced in a deeper
region of my soul more indivisible more
vast from which all obstacles and
partitions seem to have been swept away
for what had happened was that while I
recognized in this passage the same
taste for uncommon expressions the same
bursts of music the same idealist
philosophy that had been present in the
earlier passages without my having taken
them into account as the source of my
pleasure I now no longer had the
impression of being confronted by a
particular passage in one of their gods
books which traced on the surface of my
mind a purely linear figure
but rather of the ideal passage of their
job common to all this books and to
which all the similar passages now
becoming merged in it and added a kind
of density volume by which my own
understanding seemed to be enlarged I
was by no means bear God's sole admirer
he was the favorite writer also a friend
of my mother's a literary lady a
literary lady in order to finish reading
their God's latest volume dr. doom
evolved had kept all his patients
waiting and it was from his consulting
room and from a park near Cumbre that
some of the first seeds were scattered
of that predilection for their God a
very rare species in those days but now
so widespread that one finds a flowering
everywhere throughout your around
America and even in the tiniest villages
the flower both ideal and common what my
mother's friend and it would seem what
dr. dubrow both liked above all of the
writings of their God was just what I
liked the same flow of melody the same
old-fashioned phrases and certain others
quite simple and familiar but so placed
by him in such a light as to hint the
particular quality taste on his part and
also in the sad passages of his books a
sort of roughness a tone that was almost
harsh and he himself no doubt must have
felt that these were his principal
attractions for in his later books if he
had come across some great truth or the
name of a famous cathedral he would
break off his narrative and in an
invocation and a posture gave a lengthy
prayer would give a free outlet to that
affluence which in the earlier volumes
remained submerged in his prose
discernible only in a rippling of its
surface and perhaps even more delightful
more harmonious when it was thus veiled
from the eye when the reader could give
no precise indication of where the
murmur of the current began or where it
died away these passages in which he
delighted were our favorites also
for my own part I knew them all by heart
I was disappointed when he resumed the
thread of his narrative whenever he
spoke of something whose beauty had
until then remained hidden from me of
pine forests or hailstorms of noted
antibody or Italian fedra by some piece
of imagery he would make their beauty
explode into my consciousness and so
being aware that the universe can
contain innumerable elements that my
feeble senses would be powerless to
discern if he did not bring them within
my reach I wish that I might have his
opinions some metaphor of his on
everything especially on such things as
I might have an opportunity someday of
seeing for myself and among such things
particularly on some of the historical
monuments of France or certain views of
the sea because the emphasis with which
in his books he referred to these show
that he regarded them as rich in
significance and beauty but alas on
almost everything his opinion was
unknown to me I had no doubt that it
would differ entirely from my own since
his came down from an unknown world
toward which I was striving to raise
myself convinced that my thoughts would
have seen pure ineptitude to that
perfected spirit I had so completely
made a clean sweep of them all that if I
happen to find in one of his books
something that had already occurred to
me my heart would swell with gratitude
and pride as though some day and he had
in his infinite bounty restored it to me
had pronounced it to be beautiful and
right it happened now and then that a
page of his would say the very same
things that I used often at night when I
was unable to sleep to write to my
grandmother and mother and so concisely
and well that their gods page had the
appearance of a collection of epigraphs
for me to set at the head of my letters
and so to in later years when I began to
propose a book of my own and the quality
of some of my sentences
seemed so inadequate that I could not
make up my mind to go on with the
undertaking I would find the equivalent
of my sentences in their God but it was
only then when I read them in his work
that I could enjoy them when it was I
myself who composed them in my anxiety
that they should exactly reproduce what
I perceived in my mind and in my fear of
their not turning out true to life I had
more than enough time to ask myself
whether what I was writing would be
pleasant to read but in reality there
was no kind of language no kind of ideas
that I really liked except these my
anxious and unsatisfactory attempts were
themselves a token of my love a love
without pleasure but profound and so
when I came suddenly upon similar
phrases in the writing of another and
was thus free from scruples from
strictness and having no need to amend
myself I indulged to the full my own
appetite for such phrases just as a cook
who for once has no dinner to prepare
for others finds at last the time to be
a gourmet himself one day having found
him a book by bear Gogh some joke about
an old family servant to which the
writers saw the Magnificent style added
a great deal of irony but which was what
I had often said to my grandmother about
Francoise Zaza and when another time I
discovered that he thought not unworthy
of reflection in one of those mirrors of
truth that were his right hands a remark
similar to one I have had occasion to
make our about our friend Monsieur de
Gerland down and moreover my remarks on
Francois so mr. de Gaulle down which
were among those that I would most
resolutely have sacrificed for bear
God's sake in the belief that he would
find them quite without interest then it
suddenly seemed to me that my own humble
existence and the realms of truth were
less widely separated than I had
supposed that at certain points they
actually coincide
and in my newfound confidence and joy I
wept on the writers pages as in the arms
of a long-lost father